في اول تعليق له على الاوضاع في السودان
اكد الرئيس الارتريا على ضروره دمج قوات
الدعم السريع داخل الجيش السوداني لطي
الخلافات وعقلها فرقي في مقابله مع
تلفزيون الارتري ان وعد الخلافات ضروريه
لحمايه سياده السودان
سودان
يجب ان يكون للسودان جيش واحد ولا مجال
للصراع على السلطه في هذا الوقت طالما انه
سيدفع بالبلاد الى نزاعات لن تنفع احدا
يجب دمج قوات الدعم السريع مع الجيش
السوداني لتجنب الخلافات وحمايه سياده
الوطن للاسف ثوره الشعب السوداني استولى
عليها دخلاء والحرب الجاريه انحراف كامل
لذلك المسار
هكذا رئيس الاثري في مقابلات مع تلفزيون
الرسمى على ضروره ايقاف الاقتتال الدائري
في السودان داعيا في الوقت نفسه اطراف
النزاع لحل الخلافات بالتحاور تحت رعايه
دول الجوار وعدم فتح باب التدخلات
الاجنبيه
يجب اعطاء فرصه للسودان وعلى دول الجوار
ان تلعب دورا اكبر لمساعده الفرقاء لحل
الازمه وتمنع اي تدخل خارجي وان تقف الى
جانب الشعب السوداني لا خيار امام الدول
الاقليم سوى ان تتحد في وجه التحديات
الخارجيه وتبني امنه ومستقبل المنطقه من
خلال العمل المشترك على اطراف النزاع حل
الازمه الراهنه التي كانت نتيجه تراكمات
لاخطاء النظام السابق